salut aujourd'hui on est jeudi le jeudi
en général je parle un petit peu de ce
que je peux y aller vous expliquer où je
lisais toujours tous les commentaires
tous les commentaires j'y réponds au
maximum les alors je sais pas pourquoi
mais depuis trois jours vous me trouvez
les ressemblances avec des gens comme
quoi je connais personne alors j'ai
regardé sur internet et apparemment
j'aurai un air de ressemblance avec
julian mcmahon c'est sympa hein sur le
principe à l'époque de charmed
s'imaginer avec alyssa milano ya pire
pour être franc je trouve pas trop jeu
ressemblant à d'autres d'entre vous ont
trouvé que je ressemblais beaucoup à
mischa collins de supernatural celui qui
fait castiel l'ange castiel mais alors
pas du tout pas du tout alors expliquez
moi je vraiment là je vois pas un seul r
bon je sais je sais pas vous voulez pas
que je ressemble à celui qui fait digne
plutôt non battant complètement parce
qu'à la différence des deux frères j'ai
j'ai laissé mes muscles chez moi en fait
lors de mon dernier déménagement est
impossible de les récupérer
je j'envoie des lettres et on me les
rend pas et après il ya un mot qui est
revenu plein plein de fois au début
j'avais lu vite je crois que c'est vrai
c'était romain duris et puis on sait
c'est par romain c'est sylvain et
c'était pas du ris et du rif c'est pas
pareil je savais pas qui c'était en fait
j'avais déjà vu mais je ne connaissais
pas son nom si on imaginer que j'avais
un tout petit air de ressemblance avec
sylvain du rif ça donnerait sa bompard
oui évidemment je suis obligé d'enfiler
la tenue du grand monarque du christ
cosmique de tout comme en mai un porche
du rif mon nom au plan kosmix et oriana
donc j'incarne en fait l'énergie de
l'homme vert du grand monarque qui
l'annoncé par les prophéties de
nostradamus donc c'est l'énergie du
christ cosmique qui était risque presque
très humiliant c'est que même moi je
trouve que je lui ressemble
du coup je me laisserais jamais pousser
les cheveux en fait jamais vraiment
chaud c'est pas comme si moi j'étais
pariente garagiste et lui bouche etc je
suis mentaliste et ayez il est barré il
est barré et je me dis peut-être qu'à
des gens qui pensent que je suis aussi
barré que lui en fait dans un sens ça me
rend ouf pour parfaire l'humiliation il
cartonne sur internet c'est à dire que
lui l'a 38 mille abonnés je suis à dix
mille abonnés donc il est quatre fois
plus regarder quoi on devrait peut-être
faire une vidéo ensemble sylvain on peut
se donner rendez vous dans une cité de
lumière je viens chez toi je prends un
des vaisseaux dehors de la vierge marie
si on pouvait rajouter les vaisseaux
directement sur l'application de bière
ça m'aiderait beaucoup tu vois sur les
applications vtc pourrait savoir où ils
sont exactement c'est l'affection qui
nous lie tous les deux 1 common jumeaux
apparemment dans une de ses vidéos il
expliquant qu'il doit poser le téléphone
avec le khalife film l'écran parce qu'il
doit utiliser les raccourcis clavier non
pas que ce soit un geek il a pas de sous
battus peut être le grand monarque le
christ cosmique l'énergie du géant vert
ou je sais pas quoi mais t'as pas
forcément de souris alors qu'il a une
flûte par contre ça n'a rien d'un faux
avec le débat mais il aime flûte donne
son numéro de téléphone comme ça
directement sur sur internet évidemment
mais il faut pas lui laisser de message
parce qu'il ne peut pas vous rappeler ce
qu'il a pas que jadis non plus dire que
le christ cosmiques sur ce coup là il a
pu crédit la plus de souris on est quand
même pensé à lui donner un petit coup de
pouce aujourd'hui je crève l'abcès
je ne suis pas le fils caché de sylvain
du rif je ne suis pas non plus son demi
frère je ne vais pas me laisser pousser
les cheveux mais par contre je peut-être
me mettre à la flûte si vous avez envie
que je fasse une vidéo un jour avec lui
ou si vous trouvez que je ressemble
vraiment à sylvain du rif
vous pouvez laisser un petit pouce en
l'air et le cosmos entier aura compris
le message n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et aussi que vous pouvez commenter
puisque je lis tous les commentaires et
j'y réponds la majeure partie du temps
demain je mentalise ray quelqu'un en
vidéo ce sera une moralisation active
samedi masterclass dimanche
explication tour pour que vous blossier
vos amis portez vous bien et rendez vous
demain 17h pour le prochain mentale vlog
ciao